what was it like being on Big Brother a
party was like playing the game you know
it was weird because of course I knew
about the show a little bit and I got
into it cuz the last wait I have to has
this being off the grid did it feel like
the [ __ ] 90s in a way like like not
worse because we had telephones and
stuff okay it was actually newspapers
the 90s II know but but I mean like no
but you know what I mean like nineties
2000s it was just like it like looking
in our own book like you couldn't even
read we were reading the ingredients on
like milk and all these [ __ ] I don't
think you know like look the celebrities
they didn't treat us any different than
the Regular Show a shorter was expedited
located and that that was the only
difference other than that once we
walked through those doors it was just
me Omarosa quiche and I pull them who
was Rudy from Cosby show you guys might
remember Brandi Glanville from
housewives Chuck Liddell james maslow
Big Time Rush
oh hey homey that guy's great a guy did
is he loves him some james maslow in the
mirror is coming flexing on flexing my
dad boobs gonna you know I did gnarly
dad those I saw doll talk all right over
there and all I'm in that right are you
talking about ones I've only had it once
I love Taco Bell so there's two type of
people who rolled all talk or talk okay
and they're sickos like me who do both
Oh
one night Doritos Locos I'll taste like
one yeah ah plays like bad boobs just
all dab boobs you guys you'll see you
make fun of my dad boobs now can we do a
song you called dad boobs I think I will
let's do a row again on another shitty
you know say wait go to saw Big Brother
and that's it once you are closed doors
there's no communication there's no
money even talking you do like the you
know the PA system go alright guys you
just start your thing and you find these
little envelopes of like okay everybody
report
living room and it just it was one of
the hardest things I've ever had to do
because that's crazy you see the regular
version it's like hey I'm Jim I'm 23 I'm
unemployed
you know like dude I run a business I've
got kids I'm married I mean this [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] see just you just have to
disconnect from all that Yod and like I
it was so hard being I mean it was so
weird because a couple weeks and we all
got videos from home and I saw my kids
onstage hi daddy we love you and I just
started crying like that I'll be like
man I got ya just like crying I can I
haven't cried in 30 years I'm cry think
about it and it was just you're so
starved for emotions you don't you don't
see anybody and the lights are on from
2:00 to 6:00 a.m. oh so you know you see
those guys like sleeping and they got
sunglasses on you look at this huge bag
taking a nap with that that's because
the lights are on like 10 times like
this year's trying to nap and you can't
see no [ __ ] you all the ID and it's all
done to make you go and say yeah mine
and get that you know that delirium that
kind of makes Big Brother what it is
makes people go off each other and makes
people stab each other down the back and
so up and I again like I said earlier
was just not talented enough not a
threat to anybody athletically I'm not
that smart so I just weaseled my way
into the finale yeah and then I got to
the I got so I was one question away
from getting the finale which I would
have won because I would have taken Ross
who back with me who people didn't like
because he was kind of the guy running
the house and I lost 250 grand your your
you know sugar gay who took the El thing
my wife your wife's like I just like
grabbed let me tell you who took the El
if you're a big fan or watch it or not I
used to watch it all that like every day
he's like yeah every single season my
family would watch it together I love
that [ __ ] I love reality you ever seen
love island I did okay that's agree I'm
glad they brought it back
you know it was no temptation I'm
thinking up yeah love island what is a
British one it started at UK but it
started last year
correct yes yeah yeah yeah you guys
watch every one of those yeah I was just
thrown by one here ding once and you're
on like Canadian military bachelor
brother I'm like that was even on
Network I'm like your heart oh yeah oh
yeah the Mormon bachelor yeah yeah yeah
and I watched that for two years I'm
like I was to say this real quick I was
watching the best wasn't the bachelor
[ __ ] guilty I said I was gonna do it
I watch it too and I [ __ ] watched it
oh did you really
idiot so I'm watching the scene of it
dude and I just I could not get over
this [ __ ] because the bachelor at some
point he goes ah you know and this is
really important to me because my wife
is in this room and every all the girls
are like yeah like they're all smiling
but I was like chuckling in the kitchen
like that's the most insane [ __ ]
thing you could say to a room of 20
people you just don't it like you just
walk into the door you lock it you're
like like you're in here somebody is
leaving as my wife and then the others
are receptive to that yeah that's true
they're like yeah we I am no I am no I
am starting each other report and by the
end of it everyone's just smearing poop
on the wall we're all married and we
watch it you hate that good but The
Bachelor I hate The Bachelor I do too I
hear there's no middle ground on that
yeah wotcher Hey yeah I hate that I've
watched it I hate it too but so one
thing I like you guys YUM you guys
aren't married once getting married yet
so you know I like prison shows and [ __ ]
like that and she watches housewives so
we gotta meet somewhere in the middle
yeah and somehow that middle because
it's prison do it is funny yeah other
sex going on so love island what's that
British one the new season just started
it says like three and it's new episode
every day every day every day well like
that yeah great
you